-I feel such gratitude
any time any Broadway performe
uses their off day on a Monday
to spend time with me.
So, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-Seth, right?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is this you?
Am I on the Seth show?
-Well, and this is --
your show, you've been doing
this since November,
which I really tip my cap.
You have yet to miss a show.
-Yeah.
-That's really amazing.
-Eight shows a week.
We're in our seventh month
I got five months to go.
It's Atticus Finch.
-Yeah.
-It's Atticus Finch.
And it's the role of a lifetime.
And we got the reviews.
We got the critics.
We got the -- We got --
The people are coming.
-You got a Tony nomination
-That happened.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is -- This is not --
This is not the gig
where you call your agent
and go,
"Get me something better."
-Right, right.
-"Get me something better.
So, this is pretty good.
-And again, Atticus Finch,
needless to say,
this is a character --
"beloved" almost seems
like an understatement.
Did you find it daunting to take
on this role in this play?
-Oh, well, yeah.
Yes, and no.
You know, Gregory Peck
did the movie,
and he won an Oscar for it
-Yeah.
-And people revere him.
He was --
They only made the one movie
There were no other plays.
There were no other movies
And so people think of
Atticus Finch as Gregory Peck.
And the people
who love the book are --
There are three kinds of peopl
who come to the show.
The people
who absolutely love the book
And they almost clutch it
to their chest
while they're watching us,
going, "Don't ruin this."
Then there are people who
absolutely love Gregory Peck
And you're not him.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-And then,
there are the teachers.
There are the teachers who -
Months before even rehearsal
started, I had a guy.
I was at something, and he goes,
"You know, I've taught the boo
for 35 years."
[ Laughter ]
Like it was, you know,
a challenge.
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "Well, you're gonn
hate the nude scenes."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, so...
But it's -- it's --
Look, we've got them.
We come at the story
in a different way.
And especially now,
in today's America,
with race and everything
that's going on
with Trump and all that,
it's more timely than ever
-Yeah. I mean, it's incredible
that you take this work
from the '30s and --
I mean, it's sadly resonant.
You would hope
that there would be --
what was addressed then
would no longer be relevant.
And obviously, you knew that
with the undertaking of it
Was that something that was,
obviously, not even
the back of your mind
but the front of your mind
as you were putting
this production together?
-You knew that "Mockingbird"
had the chance to say something.
and so often, the American
theater is kind of forgotten
I think 2% of the populous
has ever been to a play.
That includes Aunt Martha in a
four-hour version of "Oklahoma!"
at the community theater.
-Right, right, right.
-You know, 2%.
So, when the American theate
can say something,
can have a voice,
and you see what happens
every night,
the 1,400 people that sit there,
and it's not like watching
the movie or reading the book,
which you can put down
or you can put on pause.
You're in that room,
and they've shut the doors
And when Tom Robinson,
who is 100% innocent,
is found guilty, they feel it.
It's a different experience,
and only the theater
can do that.
And with Aaron Sorkin
and Bart Sher,
everybody in the cast that
pulled this thing off
night after night after night,
we still change people.
We can still --
We send people out the doo
thinking differently, and that's
all you can ask of any play.
-No, it's an incredible --
it's an incredible undertaking
And the fact that you succee
in that is amazing.
And it must be so differen
than selling out
the Shubert Theatre in you
early days here in New York.
What were some of your
early shows like?
-Well, um...um...
[ Laughter ]
I had some success.
I was off Broadway.
-Uh-huh.
-Making 125 bucks a week.
Proud to get it.
Glad to get it.
Occasionally, though,
you did the play
that no one came to see.
-Sure.
-Even off Broadway.
-Yeah.
What does "no one" mean?
-What does "no one" mean?
You're in a hundred --
you're in --
You know, like this.
-Yeah.
-An audience about
however many people this is.
And there
are seven people out there
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's a lot of empty seats.
-Seven people.
-Yeah.
-And you are a cast of eight
[ Laughter ]
So you outnumber the audience.
-So at least you know,
worst comes to --
-And every single time
that happens --
And it's happened
more than once.
Every time it happens,
you go to the stage manager,
you go, "You know,
I think there's a union rule
where if we outnumber
the audience,
we don't have to do the show."
-Sure, sure.
-And he pretends
he's looking it up and goes,
"No, there isn't a rule.
You got to go on."
[ Laughter ]
So, you go on,
you play to the seven people
you get to intermission,
you get back out, and thre
of the people have left.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-Now I -- genuine question
Do you think --
Do you think they leave
because they don't like it
or do you think
it's just too much pressur
to be that few people?
-There's some pressure.
Especially when you go
for the laughs.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God!
You're still trying to sell it
with eight people
in the audience?
-That was a good one.
You missed it.
That, plus, I think, they're
just going, "Why are we here
This must be really bad."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This must -- What?
-No -- I mean, yeah, you think
like, "What did we get wrong?"
-"We screwed up.
We're at the wrong show."